train harder than last time as coach
Greg would say and this is such good
advice because it simplifies Progressive
overload perfectly logging every single
workout and having precise targets and
goals is all good and well but
ultimately it's a fragile approach that
leaves little room for improvisation
but if you simply train the best you can
on that day every time you work out you
will gradually see yourself improve that
can mean lifting heavier or it can mean
lifting with a slower Tempo it can be
really feeling the stretch or it can
mean doing some more reps this is why I
say you can train outside with logs and
tree branches you don't necessarily need
weights with set numbers some days you
won't feel great and you won't smash PRS
but as long as you gave it your best
shot the cumulative result will be one
of constant progress